is
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 17th edition of the
blessed strategic forum
let me thank
again
our own
gigapirnet for the composition and video
and music was performed by music for the
future orchestra
comprising of young ukrainian musicians
who found shelter in slovenia joining
forces with their slovenian colleagues
under the leadership of ziva ploy percho
thank you very much again
when preparing this year's discussion
it was uh
very clear that there are some dates
some events
which become
a part of collective memory
and represent
a point of no return
one of such dates
came about this year
and it will be forever remembered as a
day when the rule of power once again
challenged
the rule
the power of rules
on 24th february
russia attacked ukraine
processes and challenges
which will reshape our lives have been
put in motion
one president recently
said quite clearly days of abundance
are over
the truth is we need to readjust we need
to adapt
and we need to find ways
to tackle various shapes and forms of
crisis
be it security crisis be it energy
crisis be it food crisis democracy
crisis
covet climate change human rights and
the least goes on and on
and on
while confronting these challenges
our guidance should be upheld at all
times
we should not lose
our values our norms our standards
the struggle we are facing
is not an opportunity
no matter how much you hear this story
no it's not an opportunity
this
struggle is a matter of survival
our survival
in the next days
blood strategic forum is going to
address the most pertinent and
consequential
issues
to do that we are honored
that we have assembled a prominent list
of speakers
who took their time for their from their
busy schedules
to come to bled and try to contribute a
little
piece of the puzzle
called change
because they care
because they know that only honest and
open discussion
can pay the way forward to a true and
sustainable change
before i give the floor to our host
minister of foreign affairs
allow me to thank my team
bled strategic forum
believes in
change and we believe this change is
possible
this is why everyone
worked relentlessly
to make our gathering
happen
actually
over the years
i ran out of words to show my gratitude
to my team
but let me let me try once again
thank you very much
you are irreplaceable
[Applause]
and the same goes to our partners
and supporters and friends
who support us over the years thank you
also
from our side and now
let the 17 blood strategic forum begin
allow me to pass the floor to the
minister of foreign affairs of slovenia
miss tanya fayon
and gentlemen the minister of foreign
affairs of the republic of slovenia miss
tania
thank you very much dear peter you are
irreplaceable with your team too
their presidents
the madam president of the european
commission prime ministers fellow
ministers
guests dear ladies and gentlemen
a warm welcome to slovenia
to blitz
to our strategic forum
each time i visit blitz i wonder why
don't we build cities in the countryside
where the air is much cleaner
i have to confess that i borrow this one
from the collected jokes of slavo zizak
the renowned slovenian philosopher
he's one of our guest speakers and he
will share his reflections on europe and
the challenges of our time
we are delighted that we have managed to
attract so many distinguished guests
thank you to each and every one of you
joining us in blitz
the new slovenian government took office
on first june this year
at a height of preparations for the
blitz strategic forum and i would like
to take this opportunity to thank the
blade strategic forum
team for organizing this event so
excellently and for all their hard work
this year's forum takes place amid very
challenging times for europe and the
entire world
and it will not be the first time this
is the case
the last two forms took place with
restrictions due to the covet 19
pandemic
we probably all anticipated that once
the pandemic was over
the world would return to normal
but we did not anticipate that war on
european soul would become our new
reality
this new reality has chosen the main
topics of this year's event
for us and the strategic consequences
and the challenges it has created for
europe the european union and the world
allow me to highlight a few of the
challenges
first of all we should all be concerned
with the fact
that a decades-long project of reuniting
europe after the world war ii
has been halted with a war in ukraine
we do not want to see another iron
curtain in europe but unfortunately
there is little that we can do to
prevent it at this very moment
the post-cold war european security
architecture
has been seriously shaken and it may
collapse
what is important however is that we do
not close all the doors to emergency
communication
the recent worrying developments at the
zaporoz nuclear power plant have clearly
shown the importance of maintaining open
communication channels and functional
international organizations in this
particular case the international atomic
energy agency
secondly
it is vital that the existing divisions
are not exported to the global level
to some extent this is already happening
countries have started to position
themselves and alliances have been
forgotten
crisis situations like the recent one in
the taiwan state region begin to occur
new informal international formats are
also expected to emerge
while the existing formal multilateral
forums and mechanisms might become
dysfunctional
that said
some new formats have proven to be very
valuable like the one bringing together
ukraine russia turkey and the united
nations
their agreement resulting in exports of
fertilizer and grain from the black sea
port is highly valuable particularly for
underdeveloped countries
overall to say the least the situation
is very worrying for i believe the vast
majority of countries in the world which
do not have the strength and the
capacity to shape the reality
these countries the majority of us that
are destined to mostly accept the
developments
want a functional rules-based
international order
in fact we desperately need a much more
effective multilateralism
system to deal with global challenges
such as poverty inequality polarization
climate change and many other problems
slovenia is among the countries that are
fully committed to multilateralism
and continuously promote cooperation
within the u.n system
with this in mind
we are running
for a non-permanent seat on the u.n
security council for the 2024-2025
term on top of that and this is my third
point
we eu members and institutions
have to do our homework within the
european union
while we advocate against the divisions
in europe and the world we are bound to
pledge unity within the union
i appeal from this podium today to
sovereignists and populists all across
europe
not to trade eu unity
solidarity compromise and joint
efficiency for egoism
and cheap political points in domestic
political arenas
eu unity and solidarity is shared
importance for all of us
new institutions and every single member
state particularly during the current
crisis
furthermore it is important to note that
a fully functional
prosperous european union cannot be
built exclusively as the lowest common
denominator of national interests
view requires a glue
the shared values of the rule of law
human rights freedom of the media to
solidify
structure it is not only prosperity
but also these values that make europe
such an attractive place to live for all
our citizens
ladies and gentlemen
our economist just bouncing back from
the devastating blows of the pandemic
are facing new insecurities
these ones perpetrated by rising supply
and energy costs
our citizens exhausted by the covet 19
pandemic and restrictions
are facing new fears
related to growing food and energy
prices
energy diversification finding
alternative gas and oil sources to
prevent potential energy shortages in
the winter is an absolute priority for
most of the european governments
to clarify
while we will continue to rely on
polluting energy sources this winter out
of necessity
we remain fully committed to green
transition
in other words green transition is not
only our political commitment
we are firmly convinced that it is the
most important
investment in the future
related to this
let me proudly inform you the last month
on the initiative of five countries
including slovenia
the u.n general assembly adopted a
resolution
declaring the right to a clean healthy
and sustainable living environment
and extending the scope of human rights
protection to address some of the most
pressing challenges of the 21st century
ladies and gentlemen not everything is
so gloomy indeed we might have more
questions than answers but undoubtedly
we will find solutions
including with the assistance of the
blade strategic forum i'm sure your
discussions will help us find a positive
way forward
while there is solidarity there is hope
and this year we have witnessed many
manifestations of solidarity supporting
a country under attack
implementing sanctions even though we
know that they will hurt our economies
countries helping each other tackle
fires and natural disasters
people reaching out with humanitarian
assistance to their neighbors refugees
those less fortunate and many others
in slovenia and elsewhere we have
experienced a rain-free summer
a time of extreme growth
and water scarcity when fires have raged
across europe
we have seen a strong cooperation
unselfishness and the helping hand of
our people which makes me a very proud
citizen of this country
ladies and gentlemen we must remain
united in responding to our common
challenges
this quote united we stand divided we
fall which has been used many times in
the past is not just empty words as the
united nations summarized the importance
of achieving sustainable development
goals in agenda 2030
our ultimate goal must be and remain to
leave no one behind
one final thought before the end of my
address do not leave blit
without trying the soft power of this
place
the sweet cake called crimschnita
without swimming in the lake and without
enjoying a walk
around its perimeter
and all this is a part of the experience
called the blitz strategic forum i wish
you plenty of interesting debates and a
very enjoyable stay in my country our
country slovenia and thank you all for
your attention
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the republic of slovenia mr
[ __ ]
president mr president
madam speaker prime ministers
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen friends
after the second world war
the iron curtain descended across europe
dividing it into the democratic west
and the communist east
this block division
lasted until 1990s
until the fall of berlin wall
the collapse of soviet union and warsaw
pact
and the emergence of new sovereign and
democratic states
slovenia among them
so
europe has witnessed 30 years
ago a great condensing of history
with the exception of the western
balkans
it unfolded peacefully
promising a better future for a
continent
and the entire world
and today
30 years later
particularly due to the war in ukraine
it seems that a prospect of a new block
division looms over europe
it might it might once again
split it
into a democratic west
and
authoritarianist
with the border between them also
marking the boundary of russia's zone of
interest
and influence
although it might be too early to talk
about all its possible ramifications
there can be no doubt
that any new division would be bad news
for the europe
of the europe and for the world
a new block division
would imply a kind of recycling of
history
resurrecting not only the issue of
so-called hard security
but also the question of the fundamental
values including democracy
history has taught us that block
division is not a solution it is a
problem
it brings along the state of fragile
constantly threatened peace
accompanied by an arms race proxy wars
and agonizing efforts for a peaceful
resolution
if it is true
that the war in ukraine
and its consequences might lead to a new
block division
we should be concerned about whom it
will divide
and what this implies for the europe
and the international community
if president's pudding objective
is to restore and consolidate a large
sphere of influence
for the russian federation
leaving no room for the countries in
this zone to move closer to the eu and
nato
then the turmoil will last as long as it
takes for moscow to establish such a
sphere
one way or another putin will demand of
the countries along its border to make a
decision
or else
he might take the decision for them
by sanctioning them perhaps even by
force
in my speech i would like to focus on
just one consequence of this possible
new division
the question of where its border might
run in the western balkans and why
this could be the next
central question for peace and security
in europe
if it is if it is holds true
that the newly emerging russian sphere
of interest of influence we leave no
room for countries aspiring for to join
the eu and nato
then this new geopolitical division
might make the western balkans part of
the western world
this however
depends mostly on the decision taken in
brussels as much as on those taken by
countries of the western balkan
the longer the eu enlargement process
the more these countries are prone to
russia's aspiration
or at least to russia's growing
influence
this is why slovenia
has been working for years towards swift
and decisive eu enlargement to the
western balkans
this is in our view a central
geopolitical issue
it is also possible that the new block
division
might run across
the middle of the western balkans
and this is a cause for concern
i find it hard to imagine this could
unfold without security risk
in this respect
bosnia and herzegovina
seems to be of key importance
slovenia is doing everything in its
power to convince the eu and the west
to fast-track the accession of bosnia
and herzegovina to the eu and if
possible to nato
should the conflicts in bosnia and
herzegovina escalate
this might pose a serious security risk
for the country
for the region and for the europe
now it is time to understand and resolve
this problem
since
our dear guest here is also
the president of the european commission
and our dear friend
mrs
van der lion i would like to reiterate
slovenia's proposal
that bosnia and herzegovina be granted
candidate status this year
and if possible without any condition
whatsoever
for the purpose of this conference
and as a friend of serbian president
vucic
and the president of serbia allow me to
make another remark in this context
in my opinion
serbia will play a decisive role
if it is
if it is comes to the division of europe
in the western balkans
here i am referring to serbia's
traditional security political economic
cultural and emotional
attachment to russia
i would like serbia's policy to help
keep the whole of the western balkans on
the western european side
however
this is a complex issue and i believe we
must address it as such
the point is that serbia would probably
be willing to risk a break with
russia only
if given firm very firm assurance about
its place in the european union
but it's not completely sure about this
in my view
we must do
everything in our power so that our
action convinced serbia to strengthen
its political will for european
perspective
getting serbia on board with the western
european option would be in turn greatly
contribute to resolving problems in
bosnia and herzegovina
not to mention the dialogue between
belgrade and pristina
in this context we must insist on our
three expectations number one
that serbian official policy rejects the
idea of so-called serbian world serbs
number two
that serbia rejects separatist
tendencies in bosnia and herzegovina and
number three
that belgrade successfully concludes the
dialogue with christina ladies and
gentlemen
from what has been said
we can see that the european union has a
major role to play on issues related to
the
ramifications of the win and to the
situation in the western balkans
in my opinion the eu
should make a much greater effort to
draw the western balkans into its zone
of influence
and also its membership
i am aware
that some are very concerned about the
political costs
of this course of events
but experience has taught us that the
price of indecision
can be much much higher and much sadder
i believe
that there is still time to act however
consensus must be reached in brussels as
soon as possible that enlargement of the
western balkans has become become a key
geopolitical issue
in hope
that we will succeed
in this endeavors i thank you for your
attention and wish you a all successful
work at the forum thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the european commission
ms ursula von der lion
presidents
prime ministers
ministers excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
many many thanks for inviting me here to
the bled strategic forum it's wonderful
to see this packed room here
and indeed this is a form which has
become unmissable
by now as a gathering for the foreign
policy community
and as an event of european
and global relevance
it's wonderful to be here with you today
now this year's headline we've seen it
on the screen while this fantastic
orchestra was playing
this year's headline perfectly sums up
the most relevant question of our
times
will the rule of power
replace
the power of rule
and i believe that the answer to this
question
boils down to one
line
it all depends on the power of democracy
it all depends on our capacity
to uphold fundamental principles
to resist aggression
to protect our values and our friends
it is now understand the statement to
say that the world has been watching our
response
to russia's aggression
very closely
the stakes are clear to everyone
at the beginning of this year
russia and china
have openly declared
a so-called unlimited friendship
and only weeks later
russia launched its war against ukraine
weeks later
the message couldn't be more explicit
so if we are to preserve basic
principles
such as self-determination
and the un inviolability of borders
putin cannot win this war and ukraine
must win this war
this is absolutely clear
[Applause]
and this is why
we have mobilized our economic might
like never before
in a matter of days and weeks we have
approved the most far-reaching sanctions
ever implemented
and the sanctions are causing colossal
damage
to the kremlin's ability to wage war
putin himself has admitted it
and the damage will only grow over time
besides this we have supported
financially ukraine with more than 10
billion euros since the beginning of the
war and i'm not including the bilateral
support of our member states
and we are working on the next tranche
more has to come for ukraine this is
very clear my message to our member
states and we use for the first time
ever
resources from the european budget on
military equipment to sustain
ukraine's brave defense effort
we will support ukraine as long as it
takes
we are doing it for ukraine we are doing
this to uphold our european values but
we are also doing this to show
to russia and the world
that breaking internationally shared
rules
comes with a massive cost
that has to be very clear
this effort must come together with the
new european strategic thinking
and today i would like to pin down
three of its main
tenets
first
to defend the rule of law and the
rule-based order over time
we must neutralize
russia's blackmail ability and
strengthen our own capabilities to act
second
we must support democracies that are
most exposed to foreign threats and i'm
not only thinking about ukraine but also
about the western balkans
and third
we must also look further to global
geopolitical shifts and use our economic
might to preserve and expand the
rules-based global order
my first point means primarily
ending our dependence on dirty russian
fossil fuels
[Applause]
and our work here is well underway
we are diversifying our supplies at
lightning speed
the gas supplies from sources other than
russia
has increased by 31 billion cubic meters
since january this year
and this compensates by now the russian
cuts of gas supply to europe
we're also cutting substantially our
need of imported gas
because we have to prepare for potential
full disruption of russian gas
and for this
we have asked member states to reduce
the gas consumption
by 15 percent and save it to the storage
that can save up to 45 billion cubic
meter of natural gas
and ultimately the best way to get rid
of russian fossil fuels
is of course to speed up our transition
to green energy sources
every kilowatt hour of electricity
that europe generates from solar from
wind from hydropower from biomass from
geothermal or green hydrogen
makes us less dependent on russian
fossil fuels so invest in that
if you look at the facts the evidence
today the price of wind and solar
is cheaper
than polluting fossil fuels
and that's why
with our re-power eu initiative
we will invest together 300 billion
euros to accelerate the green transition
for instance we are now financing one of
the largest offshore wind farms of the
world in the north sea
and tomorrow
i will be in denmark to discuss exactly
similar initiatives a huge offshore wind
farm in the baltic sea
so ladies and gentlemen my dear friends
the era of russian fossil fuels in
europe is coming to an end
and with freedom from blackmail
we will come greater power to defend
global rules that has bee has to be our
next strategic approach
ending our dependency on russian fossil
fuels
is only the first step
the skyrocketing electricity prices are
now exposing
for different reasons
the limitations
of our current electricity market design
it was developed for completely
different under completely different
circumstances
and completely different purposes
it is no more fit for purpose
and that's why we the commission
are now working on an emergency
intervention
and a structural reform of the
electricity market
we need a new market model for
electricity that really functions and
brings us back into balance
and then we have to look of course
beyond
energy
the green and digital transition will
massively increase
our need for raw materials
take lithium for batteries
or silicon metal for chips
take rare earth
to produce magnets for electric vehicles
and wind turbines
demand for them
double
by 2030
and if you look at the european demand
for lithium batteries
it is set to increase at an annual rate
of 40
between between 2020 and 2025 40
rise per year the demand
now the good news in that is it means
that the european green deal is
progressive
the not so good news is
one country
dominates the processing
out of the 30 critical raw materials
today
10 are mostly sourced from china
so
we have to avoid falling into the same
dependency as with oil and gas
we should not replace
all dependencies with new ones
so we must make sure that access to
these commodities will not be used to
blackmail us we have to diversify the
supply and build new ties with reliable
like-minded partners around the globe
for this purpose for example i'm
traveling in two weeks to canada
like-minded partners with very
interesting offers
the power of democracy
also depends
on building strong foundations with
like-minded partners for the economy of
tomorrow
my second thought
we must strengthen those who believe
like us
in the value of rules
and bring them even closer
i'm thinking of course first and
foremost about ukraine
the kremlin's invasion aimed to pull
ukraine back towards a darker past but
instead we are seeing
the brave determination of ukrainians to
continue on their chosen path and even
speed up their process of transformation
as they rebuild their country it's
amazing to see this effort and this
determination and this passion that they
show the new ukraine i'm deeply
convinced will have stronger
institutions a modernized judiciary but
also be greener more digital and more a
resilient economy to get there
and we're aware of that ukraine will
need to channel enormous
resources for reconstruction
map investment needs
coordinate action
all of this in support
of an ambitious reform agenda so big
tasks out of us
therefore with ukraine in the lead
a reconstruction platform can achieve
these goals
a platform open to all who care about
the future of ukraine
and to advise on the best way forward we
have to be very precise it's a huge
responsibility that we have to tackle
and therefore to this purpose ukraine
together with the european commission
and the german g7 presidency
will co-host an international conference
in berlin
on the 25th of october
we will bring together in this
conference renowned experts
international organizations things tanks
academics but also and that's very
important for me the private sector and
civil society civil society because the
young people of ukraine dream of a
better future rightly so a prosperous
affair a green a more democratic ukraine
they are so right a peaceful ukraine a
flourishing ukraine and because the path
of modernization the path of democracy
is also the path that leads to the
european union we are at your side and
we want to support you in this endeavor
[Applause]
and the same is true for the western
balkans let there be no doubt
our friends from the western balkan are
part of our european family the danube
the adriatic and the balkan mountains
have always been a link
never a border
our economies are tied together after
centuries of trade and travel
so prosperity in the balkans depends
entirely on their integration in the
rest of europe
most importantly the people of the
western balkan
overwhelmingly aspired to join the
european union
yet
we know in recent years progress has
been slowed
not least by international actors
including russia
who seek to undermine
democratic institution building
and the rule of law
we have as european union
a clear strategic interest that all
western balkan 6
keep advancing advancing on the
passwords european membership
because balkan western balkan stability
is european stability and western balkan
prosperity is also european prosperity
so how can we reinvigorate the european
perspective for the western balkans
i think we must first and foremost
push the integration of our economies
even further
and that's why we have launched the
economic and investment plan of 9
billion euros funding
with the potential
of mobilizing
more than 20 billion euros of
investments for the western balkan
all of this is groundwork towards our
common future in the european union
and we must strengthen the credibility
of our accession process
we must make sure that every step
a country takes towards democracy the
rule of law and equal rights
brings it closer to the european union
that's why the opening of accession
process and negotiations with albania
and north macedonia was a true milestone
we had set clear conditions for this
and they have delivered
the people and the democracies have
delivered
it was a huge democratic success
for the people of albania and north
macedonia
but also for the rest of europe and for
our strategic interests
the best way forward
to contrast foreign influence
by autocratic countries is to strengthen
democracies in europe it is about
geopolitics yes
but it is also about our common values
and finally
we must also look beyond europe
and beyond the geopolitics of our
immediate neighborhood
the power of democracies
our ability to shape the world of
tomorrow depends greatly
on whether
we are able to have a growth model and
an economic model that works for all
a growth model that is fit for the
challenges of this century
starting with climate change and with
the digitalization of all economic
sectors
there's an urgent need to lay down a
material infrastructure of the future
world economy
one that is truly sustainable for our
planet and that delivers prosperity by
the greatest number of people
because investment and infrastructure
continue to shaping the rules of our
world
they can promote a free and fair trade
instead of financial dependence
they can protect our environment instead
of exploitation and polluting
they can build international relations
based on trust instead of economic
blackmail
this is why we have put forward global
gateway
300 billion euros of investment
this is our approach to big
infrastructure projects
value-based transparent
open to the private sector
infrastructure that delivers lasting
benefits to local communities
and by doing so we want to show the
power of a value-driven investment
agenda
we know
what investment by other countries can
look like
take for example russia
the price to pay for oil and gas
is loss of sovereignty
and loss of independence
they don't want partners
they want vassals
and it's not just the kremlin
tens of countries are on the brink of
default
because they cannot pay their debt with
china
and a few have
already defaulted
the financial times calls it emerging
birth and road debt crisis
development loans
that ignore environmental and social
standards
that cuts short on risk management and
lag transparency
cannot deliver what countries need
there is a better way
and it is up to us to make it work in
all corners of the world
it is not just the future
of several countries that hangs by a
threat
it is the future of the rules-based
order
this is our responsibility as
democracies of our days and our age and
i want europe to live up to it
for our own sake and for the world's
sake
and therefore thank you for listening
have a great conference and long live
europe
[Applause]
thank you very much
mr president uh and all the speakers
with this we conclude
the opening of the 17th bletch strategic
forum and now we are going to continue
with the
leaders
panel
and the leaders panel
is going to be moderated
but
[Music]
you